si vous appuyez sur ce bouton la moitié
de la population mondiale mourra
mais si vous n'appuyez pas dans 100 ans
le genre humain s'éteindra
vous et pull team espoir de l'humanité
je vous ai laissé deux pistes
la plus rude jusqu'ici
inferno sera au bout de celle ci et
aubrystes
gilbert amérique il a déclaré que
quelqu'un devait prendre les choses en
main
il a laissé cette carte
c'est une sorte d'énigme
chercher trouver
zobrist a créé une épidémie
si cette piste existe imaginez le nombre
de pays qui doivent la convoitée
tout faire pour s'en emparer sans le
professeur langdon impossible de trouver
ces les russes
vous fier à personne
il ya tellement bien je
je veux être certaine d'être du bon côté
rappelé
l'heure est venue notre renaissance est
pour aujourd'hui